is it hot in here
it's hot in here it's a hot one
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by ciel she's a
global pop music icon who's back with
her long-awaited debut studio album
alpha which is set to release on october
20th and to hold you over she has new
single aptly titled spicy she's got the
sauce we've got the sauce ciel welcome
to the show
yes thank you for having me thanks so
much for coming in and while we're on
the topic of spicy what's going through
your head as we prepare for this
gauntlet like are you are you a fan of
hot sauce honestly
i don't i'm not good with spicy food
yeah
but i do love hot sauce
so you just take a bite you just take a
bite
what a weird
date
girl
also eating on camera i i don't think
i've ever done that before whoa we got
the exclusive
[Laughter]
that's good
alpha is produced under your
self-managed venture very cherry i'm
curious what sorts of freedoms an
example of a freedom that you think you
had making this record that maybe you
wouldn't have had releasing it under a
more traditional record label i come
from a very traditional k-pop system
and you know i learned so much and
that's how cl was created so i'm very
grateful for that but you know
i've been
doing this for a while so i wanted to
have more freedom to explore and expand
and learn
more with cl like creating the world for
her
was that spicy for you you know not the
you know thankfully you know this would
be they're not that this would be a
labor for me if that first one hit you
know to me it's just kind of nice
and we work our way into a nice place
this next one kind of a nice color yeah
this is the yellow bird bliss and
vinegar
okay
let's try it out let's try this
while you're going for it you're kind of
going for it so i'm dropping i'm just
trying to hang mm-hmm
so you get a lot of dude credit for your
stage shows and really shine as a
performance artist and you once said
dance is not a 5 6 7 8 to me it's just
how i meditate if forced to choose which
cl music video do you think has the best
choreography oh
for me
i love i love the spicy performance that
i did recently
and you know hello [ __ ] with paris
and her team
um
like that really like created a new
category for me so yeah those are my
favorite i can't yeah i shouldn't but
those are those two are my favorite
how does rapping on the comeback stage
at inkigayo with a parrot i can't
believe you said inkigayo right now
i did it's so weird
to hear it from you here but you love it
yes rapping with a parrot on your
shoulder how does that complicate a live
performance
oh wow
that one okay also there were like swans
everywhere and like yeah
yeah birds involved um
it kept biting my hair
yeah it kept biting it and talking to me
it was interesting but yeah it was like
i would never i don't know if i'll ever
do that again but it was a fun
experience
[Music]
the color looks more red yeah that's a
little more intense yeah
i don't feel this but i see it
you know what
be careful yeah exactly be careful about
that
so believe it or not we cover fashion
quite a bit for a chicken wing talk show
hosted by a bald guy in his 30s but for
you for you we have to someone who vogue
once described as catnip for
photographers and then in 2013 your og
girl group 21 did a collaboration with
chrome hearts which now almost 10 years
later that's like every rapper's
favorite designer how would you explain
the aesthetic appeal of that brand to
someone who wouldn't know tom ford from
tom hanks hmm
damn i can't believe you know that first
of all
um
i bought my first piece actually in hong
kong when i was 12. i was such a fan of
it so i went there by myself um didn't
tell you know any of my family members
and bought my first piece
and you know had it on on my special
occasions and met
um jessie jo who's the daughter of the
starks family and became really great
friends and we performed together when
she was back in korea and
it was like a dream to me to collaborate
just making something creating something
new with my friend so it became that
which is more fun and i think it's
awesome that it's a big thing now but
yeah
it's like i'm a personal fan of the
brand and have always been what's your
all-time favorite cl fashion moment and
then what would you say was your most
regrettable red carpet look or wardrobe
don't ask me that
regrettable and then you're gonna
everyone looking on my regrettable
can i be really honest with you
please be honest with me i don't
remember
oh you remember i know it's i know it's
in i know it's no sitting there right
now
not regrettable but i
was actually the first one to wear um
giancagliano margela
dress as a
asian um figure and pop star whatever it
is musician
and
it looked like it was like the
life-saving tube
[Laughter]
like you were drowning in the ocean and
they threw yeah there was a lot of memes
after that
so not regrettable but that was not what
i was going for for sure
so as we mentioned your music videos
like a high art form do song concepts
ever come to you first as visuals or is
that always a secondary thought
first of all it's what i want to talk
about
and then
it's a character i build
once that message and who she is is
created everything that i want to talk
about comes and flows naturally
so that's the process of it
and then i know that you relish the
freedom of being a solo artist but i'm
curious are there any musical tools that
you picked up being in a mega famous
girl group that still serve you today
i think
being able to
work be work with three very different
type of characters like together as a
group i learned so much from them like
homes vocal is amazing and just learning
how she you know talks even helps a lot
just sonically and you're just around
that all the time so
just things like that you know it's just
naturally soaked into me and they're
they are a part of me always they will
always be
[Music]
i am actually doing better than i
thought i would
you're doing great this one is a little
bit of a stop up though
right on cue i don't want
[Music]
[Music]
damn i had to say that right before
right no it always happens that always
happens
you know what what is what is going on
so what's in this thing so i'm right
with you this is a this is a hot number
five one of the hotter fives that we've
ever had
you have scorpion you have fire roasted
bell pepper it has kind of a buffalo
sauce to it but i think it's that
scorpion pepper that really
dominates and kind of shines in this one
yeah but it's okay see how while you
cool down on that we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so i'll
pull up the picture on the monitor you
just tell us the bigger story
your song spicy features narration from
john malkovich and it's clear from
scrolling the page that you guys have
known each other for years uh it's an
intriguing friendship how did you guys
become close
so
um pete berg invited me to be um
a part of his movie mile 22
and he was my
uh
he was the leader of the agency thing i
was the role i was supposed to play
i did play um
and we just got along because he comes
from theater
and i connected to his story so much and
he's my mentor when i was making spicy
for some reason i just sent it to him
and i just had the first verse and he
heard that and sent me a five minute
monologue and i had to i
chopped that up and made that intro
he's like yeah the spicy sauce yeah
korea yeah he just freestyled it and
sent me like voice note on
you know iphone voice note and
that's how it ended up being in the song
[Music]
are you ready to move on to the back
half can i say no
[Music]
the last one was really
it hit me it's jarring right
it spiced on me
but nothing cl can't handle
oh going you know this is on your
recommendation
yes this is the korean
um
i don't even know what that is to be
honest but it's kind of like a yogurt or
something it is it is but
sweeter and smoother
refreshing yes it helps the
spiciness i might keep this on the table
do do it there's that
called cool
piece and um
i don't think you guys had it here but
that one really works all right well
i'll try to go deep into the catalog
yeah
so i'm often spammed by fan groups
online who are angling for whoever they
support to be on the show yeah but
nothing and i mean nothing compares to
the size scale and organization of k-pop
fans what would you say like
distinguishes them from other stan
groups elsewhere in the world it's
always the simple things that i love you
know it's
because
when was the last time like we actually
wrote
a handwritten letter to someone
and there's you know they do that and
yeah those simple things are the best
i came in today i got a i got two
wedding invitations oh amazing a fan
wedding yeah yeah oh crazy yeah i never
got one of those that's never something
to aspire to wow
damn
thanks for the invite guys
[Music]
what is this
this is like um there's scotch bonnet
you've got trinidad scorpion you got
ghost pepper so it's kind of like a
greatest hits of the super spices
[Music]
story checks out
no
how how are you doing
well um you know i don't i my guess is
this episode
falls in the season somewhere close to
the launch of your album
i know yeah but
for me and it's the first shoot of
season 16.
so i've had a couple weeks off so it's
always tough to get back back
yeah so
i'm going through it just like you
chase it yeah cheers
like
yeah i you know what it's their choice
like people choose to do this to
themselves right right yeah and you
yeah
just like you today yeah
that was my choice
yes
down yeah yeah well wait and wait to try
the next one but before that this this
this reaction that we're having it's
kind of a lovely segue cause i'm curious
if somebody who's traversed the world
how does korean spicy compare to other
cuisines like is there something unique
about the heat and korean cooking it's
very spicy
at the same time i can't really talk
because it's like there's a lot going on
right now yeah like i missed your
questions
am i like high right now you know what
like am i high up that's that's i might
be that's not an uncommon response you
know like uh the endorphins that kind of
kick you get kind of a headache i feel
like i'm dreaming right now i will not
remember this tomorrow
we're floating we're just floating
through it
and then i see these uh i see these two
hands korean style hot dog chains kind
of popping up all over the place now uh
what are your thoughts on the korean
corn dog overrated or underrated
uh oh my god have you tried those yeah
yeah i've had i've gotten some funky uh
which one have you tried there's like
well they have all these different kinds
like they're deep frying it and like
sprinkling it with like the mustard on
the outside and all that stuff i think
it's great um
hangover food and some people eat it for
dessert did you know that
they however as dessert with like sugar
on it or cream or like cheese there's
different types but i love them
yeah lots of innovation with the corn
dog here we innovate with the chicken
wing and speaking of
are you ready to move on to that i'm
scared of that one
yeah
you've been told maybe you've been
briefed by people that are like watch
out for de bomb i mean
yeah
it says itself
beyond insanity
[Music]
are you ready i'm ready if you're ready
okay
[Music]
what
stop
i think i took
a big fight you did you did you took a
big bite
oh my
have you tried this before
cabrera is not
oh my god i know
you warned me but
[Music]
i know mm-hmm
am i red
no you look great you look great it's a
nice
a nice wingate glow nice winged glow
damn that is spicy crazy is that the
spiciest thing you've ever eaten
yes
officially
are you sure this is like
pepper or like it's like
so what's it's been described as battery
acid guests have described it as poison
before i it is you're like you almost
like want to reject it or something i
don't i don't think you're supposed to
put that on food no i i i agree with you
i agree with you
they were like so excited about this me
being here yeah
that's there death stare to the couch
downright gleeful i gotta say
they're
way too much
they are enjoying it way too much
i don't know what to do
it's all right it's all right we're
almost we're almost to the finish line
now i'll just kind of i'll try to gas
pedal it i'll race to the finish line
you look great you look great
but here's what i'll say just be careful
around your eyes because that's
sometimes a mistake people can make you
know
just don't touch your eyes don't touch
your eyes
son i'm on a mission to learn how to say
that spicy in as many languages as i can
through this show how would you describe
like what you just ate vela what does
that mean
spicy
[Applause]
how are you dreaming i'm floating
it's all surreal
it's abstract
what a bizarre interview
oh my god
i will never forget this interview
this next one is cranked it's from our
friends at hellfire as you can tell by
the cover
[Music]
art you know after that
right how bad can it get
i feel i feel my face like
swelling up
yeah i feel it
i'm almost like numbing maybe i'm like
going down my lips are numb yeah
it's like i'm to a point where i'm like
calm
now
you know you know when you're like very
angry you become calm yeah well all
right i'm just going to keep an eye out
in case the table gets flipped or
something
just kidding um
oh my god yes
so during season two of the fx show dave
and your appearance you you go into this
tinted black car and you put on an led
face mask is that just for the show or
can you personally speak to the benefits
of light therapy um
i'm pretty sure i can
you should have asked me that question a
couple sauces ago
but yeah do it yeah let's take care of
ourselves
that's all i can say right now yeah like
all the data
is like
numbed right now in my uh brain
but yes i do that and it's great when
you travel and you know
but
yeah
what am i talking about it's it's going
great you're doing great seal and then
you get assassinated in that peterberg
directed action thriller mile 22. what
are the mechanics of doing that perfect
going limp and falling to the floor
after taking a head shot
oh wow you know
yes we were giggling after what happened
and i was with john
and also like more than you think you
are moving the action needed to be
bigger when i was filming that
all right
okay
last one the last one
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
app cause it's tradition around here to
put a little extra on the last one you
don't have to okay if you don't want to
notes
you know what i i i know what the bomb
tastes like now tastes like nail polish
that's a first and i think that's
accurate right
i mean never tasted it before but i
think that's how it would taste but you
know see all the coconut palette that
can find the coconut and sauce number
two yeah can find the nail polish and
sauce number eight
you put a lot on on it
you know i'm not trying to be a showman
or anything i think i just uh
i think i just got the shakes with the
bottle it happens to me a lot over here
actually you'd think i'd be better at
this by now oh my god okay cheers cheers
last one
[Music]
that one is spicy too
you know
as advertised
that's kind of the show but you know
what but you know what what
cl
thankfully though it is the last stop
aboard the scoville express and we want
to close with an obsession that's close
to your heart you told women's weekly
singapore i love disney to be honest my
mother told me i used to love dumbo and
bambi she said i watched it 5 000 times
and on my playlist these days is disney
music i know this puts you on the spot
but as a pop music icon what to you is
the single best disney motion picture
original soundtrack of all time
under the sea
it always puts you in a happy mood under
the sea mood with sebastian you got
ariel yeah little mermaid yeah and let
me tell you seal being under the sea and
ice cold sea that would feel good right
right now but you know what ciel
you made it through the wings of death
taking them on challenging yourself the
spiciest wings that you've ever eaten in
your life the spiciest food that you've
ever had in your life you know what you
didn't quit you marched forward you
stayed on top and now there's nothing
left to do seal but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
i have my new single out spicy
and
my album alpha
october 20th and i'm actually making
kimchi powder wow too so i'm excited
about that i'm gonna send it to you guys
so
you could try sean i will look forward
to it see y'all
thank you so much great job thank you
i powered through this with you
oh my god i had so much fun i don't
remember
like the some parts but
yeah this is made it through in the
dream state
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody this is
sean evans i just wanted to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and as you know every season it's out
with the old and in with the new hot
sauce lineup and i know you've been
watching this episode and wondering to
yourself i wonder if i would cry like
that would i sweat would i scream well
now you can find out because the hot
ones 10 pack is available at
heatness.com that's heatness.com to get
your hands on the hot ones 10 pack
remember with the last ab you don't have
to if you don't want to keep milk on
hand keep ice cream at the ready you can
do this
[Music]
you